afuera del centro de bienestar de este
suburbio obrero de Río familias enteras
hacen cola algunos incluso han dormido
aquí con la esperanza de recibir por fin
El auxilio Brasil el beneficio social
creado bajo el gobierno de bolsonaro que
acaba de ser aumentado en casi 40
dólares justo antes de las elecciones
desempleados y residenciados en la
vecina Favela de mareé yoiani Elí y
Johnny Siempre han votado por la
izquierda Pero esta vez el presidente y
sus valores profamilia han ganado su
voto
tengo un hijo de 4 años y estoy
embarazada no tengo trabajo así que esta
ayuda es muy valiosa para mí para
pagarme alquiler mis compras mis
medicamentos también recibimos un cupón
para ayudar a comprar gasolina
quién te ayuda te bendice y para mí ya
ir bolsonaro es una bendición soy
cristiana y votaré por él porque ha
demostrado que apoya a las familias
aunque no esté de acuerdo con todo lo
que dice está del lado de la familia
Jair bolsonaro no solo Ha logrado ganar
nuevos votantes en los barrios pobres
que solían ser bastión de la izquierda
sino que también ha conquistado muchos
pueblos pequeños y rurales
en el estado de ríos San joset valleduo
prietos la localidad que más voto a
favor del presidente y candidato en la
primera vuelta su apoyo ha crecido En
comparación con 2018 la mayoría de los
residentes son cristianos evangélicos
como él pero no es la única razón grande
defensor de los terratenientes
bolsionaron su poco placer a estos
pequeños productores en medio de la
escasez trayendo fertilizantes desde
Rusia
desde nuestro punto de vista Esperamos
que obtenga más fertilizantes y
productos del exterior para ayudarnos a
los productores pero también para ayudar
a la economía de Brasil como lo hizo al
bajar el precio de la gasolina que se
disparó y nos afectó mucho
claro
Parece ser más sincero Aunque coincido
en que se equivocó durante la pandemia
se retrasó en la compra de vacunas y
mucha gente murió por eso creo que será
una mejor opción que Lula para mí
Estos son votantes conservadores
moderados con una cosa en común el miedo
a que regresen al poder Lula y la
izquierda a quienes consideran corruptos